Being here in Dublin,...
...the people are so nice.
You literally can't stop for more than ten seconds...
...without someone coming over and saying,...
..."Do you need help? Where are you going? What do you need? Anything!"
It's even more green than I expected and it's beautiful.
We're in Saint Patrick's Cathedral.
There's so much to see in here, from the stained glass to the statues...
...or just the floors and the ceiling itself.
That's my first bite of fish and it was good!
It was crazy to leave the city of Dublin for a day trip,...
...and suddenly being in a countryside where it's breathtakingly beautiful.
I think it's, overall, a very eye-opening experience...
...to have a tour guide there to tell you about everything...
...rather than walking around and having to figure it out by yourself.
We're here at Trinity College right now.
It's a gorgeous campus.
It's older than the entirety of United States, which is pretty remarkable.
The Irish dinner was so great,...
...and it was just a night of laughing and having fun...
...and watching great traditional music.
Being loud and being crazy just made us all bond even more,...
...and it was a great time.